[Music]
Angelina Jolie giving us a super rare
glimpse inside her home life with all
her kids and all her pets
yeah that's an iguana and that's a
rabbit just hopping around the house
[Music]
they get ready with me video was shot
before the big Maleficent mistress of
evil premiere in Hollywood on Monday and
it shows all the work that went into the
big night tailors were literally sewing
Angelina into her custom Versace dress
minutes before she got into the car but
it all paid off
Angelina stunned on the red carpet
alongside five of her six kiddos that's
packs Shiloh Vivian on the Left Sahara
and Knox on the right of course
Angelina gushed over the family night to
ET it's a family affair tonight you
brought all the kids you know moms
everywhere saying how the heck does she
do that and make it look so easy
wrangling them all and having they
wrangle me honestly they're they're more
together Zahara is the most organized in
the family she looked gorgeous that
dress Jenna was beautiful it's growing
up so beautifully it's just so wonderful
to have their there any other my friends
the only jolie-pitt kid who couldn't
make it that night was Angelina's oldest
Maddox he's away at college in South
Korea and Angie has been more than open
with et about dealing with that big life
change do you have the ugly cry can't
imagine Angelina having a pet but did
you have the ugly crack embarrass your
children ugly cry I'm more dude like I
just I also just at some point at the
big glasses and I can't say who's like
the amount times I turned and waved it
was like I do know is the one moment my
life I think I turned around six times
before like the airport just kind of you
know to just you know and he's sweetly
stayed and kept waving knowing that I
was going to keep turning her and you
could feel it he he knew he couldn't he
would you know what he was feeling that
to somebody because I tried to be cool
when my mom dropped me off but inside I
was like don't worry mama so he was
feeling that - he's pretty it's nice to
know that he knows how much he's
yeah well he'll be back soon enough like
I haven't already set my plane now
Angelina actually got to reunite with
Maddox at the Japan premiere of the
movie on Thursday how cute is that is it
we're just stands a whole family
actually hold that bat I don't want to
know if it is but that's all we've got
for you for now make sure to stick with
ET for all things Angelina and her fam
until next time I'm Katie crafts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]